[Music]
it's hard to overstate the damage the
biden administration has done to the
united states over the past couple of
weeks they abandoned hundreds of
american citizens in afghanistan
including school children
even as they imported thousands of
unvetted afghan tribesmen into the
united states
and then on the way out as one final
insult they armed the taliban which is
now the best equipped army of its size
in the world it's all beyond belief most
people are stunned by it
but we've got to be honest and tell you
that the bidet administration didn't do
this alone they've had a lot of help
over a very long time from the reckless
neoconservatives who run our foreign
policy establishment
the main reason americans were so
shocked by the fall of kabul last week
is that for years people in washington
have been lying to them about it and
telling them everything in afghanistan
is just fine it's improving forever
improving
our sacrifice is well worth it our
strategy is successful just keep sending
us money and young soldiers we will make
the world safe for america for decades
that's what they've told us
one of the main mouthpieces for these
lies has been senator lindsey graham of
south carolina graham identifies as a
republican but his views in real life
are indistinguishable from say tony
blinkins or mark millie's graham's real
constituents are in permanent washington
not in south carolina
we've pulled together tonight three
representative sound bites that tell you
the story of lindsey graham's personal
responsibility for the debacle now on
display in afghanistan here's the first
of them this is from 12 years ago in it
graham explains that as an obama
superfan he is totally in favor of
sending 35 000 more troops to fight a
pointless war despite the fact he knows
perfectly well that many of them will
die watch
when it comes to afghanistan i am
completely supportive of the
president-elect's decision to send 35
000 troops into afghanistan they're
needed i would like every american to
know that not only are the troops needed
unfortunately casualties are likely to
increase
but we have a game plan in afghanistan
that i think justifies the expenditures
of blood and treasure that's about to
come
nuzzling with obama telling us that
unfortunately casualties will increase
but we have a game plan in afghanistan
that i think justifies the expenditures
of blood and treasure
so now's the moment to ask really
lindsey graham what exactly was that
quote game plan and at what point did
you realize that it wasn't working
well if graham ever knew that his plans
were failing somehow he forgot to
mention it to the rest of the country
so here he is two years later telling us
that we're really really close to
winning in afghanistan and not just in
afghanistan but also in tunisia egypt
libya syria and yemen
this clip is hard to watch but please
make yourself
we're on the verge in my view
of turning this thing around i see
afghanistan
tunisia
egypt
libya
syria
yemen
is incredible opportunities
to change the world for the better if we
as congress
accelerate the withdrawal schedule
because it's popular at home
we will undercut all the gains we have
made
so the beauty of videotape is it lives
forever that was 10 years ago
afghanistan tunisia egypt libya syria
yemen lindsey graham described them all
as little laboratories to test his
theories
all those places still exist there are
still countries the question is how are
they now
has any one of those countries been
improved by lindsey graham's game plan
that's a good question you have to ask
the people who live in those countries
many of whom have since fled as refugees
to germany and sacramento california
lindsey graham himself has not weighed
in on the results of his game plan he
doesn't like to look backward reflection
suggests accountability if there's one
thing lindsey graham is strongly opposed
to it's that
instead by this spring lindsey graham
had dropped the talk of winning the war
against terrorism or bringing democracy
to the great unwashed those were
yesterday's goals the new justification
for keeping troops in afghanistan was
the fight for global feminism we've sent
marines to kabul to tear down the
patriarchy lindsey graham told us
keep in mind that lindsey graham said
this with a straight face right into the
camera
and here's the saddest of all news
as difficult as afghanistan has been and
will be
things have changed
i went over right after the fall of the
taliban
today there are
over 6 million women who've been
educated
kabul is a very commerce driven area
people can sing and dance and live their
lives without the oppression that the
taliban
brought on them
oh he's been going there for 20 years
we're sad to tell you tonight that
lindsey graham's dream has died the last
gender studies class in afghanistan has
shuttered its doors everyone in that
country is now thoroughly binary
so the question is was the whole
experiment worth it we'd love to know
what lindsey graham thinks about that
you see him on television quite a bit
all the time on his never-ending
fundraising tour i'm a conservative send
me money
it's political televangelism but weirdly
lindsey graham won't come on this show
and that's a shame because it would be a
worthwhile conversation for everyone the
invitation remains open hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else